all right maria
maria uh where'd you grow up where are
you from uh and alley i was born and
raised in l.a los angeles california and
uh tell me about your family growing up
you had both your parents i had a
wonderful childhood i had good parents
came from my mother was a church-going
lady my father was a he worked he was a
mechanic
i had a very good childhood growing up
you know never was abused by my family
loved
it's just
things happened to me
along the way
what kind of things were going on that
are you alluding to
my brother-in-law he used to
when my when the trust from my parents
take me and
like they say they really groomed the
pedophiles really groomed their
people whoever they're
you know preying on
because
he won the trust he he he had me scared
and it's just one thing left to another
with him and uh
you know it was just terrifying that i
went through all this as a child
because no child should go through that
so your family never got wind of it they
never found out no they never knew i
never told nobody never even until this
day i've never told nobody was it right
yeah oh absolutely
this is the first time i'm telling my
story about this oh wow yeah
you know i got to start somewhere right
how many years has it been this has
happened i believe in the late 70s
early and yeah late 70s
yeah
you carry it with you all these years oh
yeah i mean it really defined my life
the majority of my life tell me how it's
done that
by
my drug use
needing me to use heroin at a young age
couldn't be a mother to my son
you know
uh it really did it really it really
defined my life it just took over my
life it controlled every aspect of my
life the drug use did yeah absolutely
but the drug use led to less cause yeah
because of the trauma that i went
through you're trying to forget about
right exactly that's how i dealt with it
you know
especially when you don't tell nobody
about the situation you're dealing with
your own self
it's pretty i don't know i had a hard
time dealing with it
but somebody needs to know i mean this
thing happens you know back in my time
our management talked about stuff like
this in the family you know we didn't
think it would happen to our family
but it does in life it really does
you know i had good parents i had loving
parents
they did nothing wrong
but trusted somebody
this is a relative yeah my
brother-in-law
yeah
yes
and you've had kids of your own i have
one son
i couldn't be a mother to him i couldn't
even raise him
because of my drug habit because my use
you know i could function
and after that i didn't have more
children because of that simple reason
well i'm going to bring children in this
world to suffer along with me i had a
long addiction of heroin
you know
it just doesn't go away
it's hard heroin is a very hard diction
it's all about terminology in your mind
because you have that addictive way in
your brains
but you need to
reprogram
and that's what i wanted but i still do
the
drinking and the marijuana
so you put down the heroin yeah oh
absolutely i have 10 years under my body
i end up losing my leg behind heroin
yeah i had and getting the bad infection
and i lost my hip bones
prevents me from standing on this leg i
have no upper femur bone
i got a lot of infection in my bones
yeah
so now in 2011 i lost my leg
but through those years the whole 25
something years that i used heroin and
dictated my life it controlled my life
so absolutely no longer
no it's not no i'm blessed i'm very
blessed
where i'm living that you know
temptations are here but
it's my determination up here that gets
me
you know about what i want to do in life
i'm too old for all this
you know
and i think sometimes god does things
for a reason and he did slow my life
down and which it really helped because
i don't wake up to the needle no more
that's the whole blessing out of
everything actually that's i can really
laugh and say that
i got the best life now than ever than i
did before
does that sound crazy
yeah because i can be happier i don't
have to wake up to that needle do you
know what it is to wake up to a needle
every day just the function just for
your day data function
that's what it is
especially with heroin you're still
using alcohol now yeah i drink and i
smoke weed
yeah
but i need to get rid of that too
because that's not the solution
that is not the solution that's not the
way to go
because i'm only hurting myself and
nobody else
you know
what is your biggest regret looking back
at your life uh my biggest not reporting
him
that's my biggest regret
not reporting him like i said in our
family we didn't talk about that stuff
and we didn't think it
could happen to any family but he used
to threaten me
and my sister and i didn't want nothing
to happen to her
you know so
like they say they they know how to
groom their
their print their prey you know
they know what they're doing you're
protecting your sister oh yeah
absolutely
yeah
he knew exactly what he was doing
because he never put me on the bed or
anything he always put me in the hallway
you know because
you know
i guess i don't know but he's just very
fortunate that he never got reported
that i never reported him
because i leave my eyes once a pedophile
always a pedophile
especially if you've never been caught i
know he's under the radio and i know he
still does it because like i say once a
pedophile always a pedophile
those things don't go away just like
that
what emotions do you deal with
oh my emotions are
i beat myself so i know i'm not the
blame to what happened to me
but if i would have said something and
wouldn't
you know i really
beat myself up for that but my emotions
are really
i mean my best relationship and
interferes in my relationships
oh yeah
and my friendships and my
interests me really because i'm so
abusive
towards my people my friends people that
care about me
and i think it has a lot to do with my
abuse
because these people are so good i'm
good people too don't get me wrong but i
see this pattern in me where i'm very
abusive
and i think it's because of my abuse and
that's not cool
you don't do that especially the people
that help you and want to be there for
you
you know what i'm saying
that's not right
so i'm working on those things you know
i'm getting out for all my issues now
it's about time
it's been over somewhat 30 some years
and never know telling you yeah i got to
seek out somewhere i got to start from
somewhere it's got to be hard to go
through your life and never never speak
about it yeah right exactly and this
like i said was the very first time i've
ever talked about it my family doesn't
even know i'm doing this video you know
no
they have no clue about what happened to
me as a child
no clue
[Music]
and he has daughters you know my nieces
and he has grandchildren you know
it's just crazy
what do you worry about now at this
point in your life that he's not doing
it to some other child that's my biggest
thing
you know and i believe myself because if
i would have reported him he'd probably
be in jail or you know because those
things
you know he would be under the you know
where he could be looked at you know
and at this point he's not because he's
never been in trouble for it
and i know that for a fact because i
know the the family history you know
we're still all
my nieces and everything all still in
contact with him
so i drop in and see how
things are going and you know i ask just
to see where things are you know i know
where he lives and everything
but you know i have no proof of it when
this began for you at what age for me
the molestation
when i was in fifth grade i believe i
was uh maybe about 12 11 somewhere
around there so it kind of derails your
childhood yeah of course i was just a
child
yes
yes i i growing up uh
a generation is completely from the
generation nowadays you know
i mean it wasn't back like i mean
it's just complete i think it's
completely different at the height of
your heroin use
what uh what kind of stuff were you
getting into oh
stealing and and
bringing into homes
going to jail and you know all this you
came with the that stuff you know and
one thing i met this guy in 1982 i was
just getting released my first prison
turn went to prison breaking into a home
in 1980 there was a new law break into a
home you go to prison
so we were breaking into homes
residential burglary met this black man
and
i got involved with him he started to
show me the trades of prostitution
actually he used to prostitute me
and that was my lifestyle for about 15
years of my life with him he was your
family until yeah until i broke away
you know enough is enough
uh yeah that was something i used to go
through torture he used to beat me with
the in the tub with the water running
with a hanger yeah
i remember that stuff like it was today
yeah i used yeah i went through a lot of
abuse
because i know
my family didn't raise me to be that way
you know i know that for a fact but i
just took that path as i got older
you know i made the wrong decisions in
life
but it took a beat that just because
what that happened it took a big impact
in my life it sure did
it sure does and everybody deals with
their
situation in different ways you know
it's no excuse but for it but people do
deal within different ways
you know
so your advice for somebody who's going
through something similar to what you
went through yeah seek the help
absolutely find help tell somebody it's
okay
because you did nothing wrong absolutely
you're not at fault
no don't hold it in because it will
determine your life
it will determine your life if you let
it
look at those the other elizabeth smart
those other ladies look at how they
overcome them they didn't turn to drugs
or anything but they seeked good health
basic good professional help they got
you know because they have the money
they have the resources but some people
aren't unfortunate like them
you know
and it is what it is with society
nowadays
you know
it's crazy
and you're living on skid row today yeah
i stayed skid row yeah
yeah i'm waiting trying to get into low
health uh low income housing yeah yeah
it's just due to this
all this what happened to me as a child
really had a big impact on my life oh
yeah the path your life took oh yeah
absolutely
especially if you don't talk about it
you know because it's a constant
reminder it's always there
you know
it's it's just
for me it really defined my life
but i'm glad i had the opportunity to
talk about it and let another people
know that
if you're a child or even adult
you know
if you're getting abused it's not okay
it's not it's unacceptable
nobody should go through that nobody
shame is a huge part of keeping it quick
yeah yes it is
shame yeah because you feel guilty you
feel that paul but no you're not
you're not at fault you got to know that
and eventually you will see it
because you'll start questioning
yourself about it because i used to meet
myself up thinking i was at fault but
it's not you're not at fault
just tell somebody and trust me you'll
get the help that you need
maria what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
um my important lesson if you are being
abused or
any kind of
abuse that you're going through just
report it tell somebody get some help
for it because the pattern will keep
going if you let it it will not change
once a man puts his hands on you seek
help because he will keep doing it he'll
say he's sorry and sorry time out and
make up but the pattern will return and
it'll keep going just like if you're
sexual abuse by your partner whoever
that takes advantage
of you or bullying you
seek help because if you don't it's not
going to go away it's going to be there
it's going to attack you you're going to
be it's prey in other words because he
know he can get away with this he knows
he can do this do you
and don't let him say anything don't let
it happen to you please he knows he
knows you won't say anything right
exactly and he knows that you're not
gonna say anything but that's okay to
say something it's it's all right
because at the end there's consequences
that he has to deal with because there's
laws
that he has to go by and that's
unacceptable
nobody should go through abuse i don't
care if it's a man or woman
because nowadays there's women that
abuse men too not just only men abusing
women
you know
crime rate is so up on women there's so
many men and women that are in prison
that are doing lifetime sentences for
killing and their spouse and things like
that because they've been abused
and
oh yes there's in 1980 there was only
two prisons
that was ciw and crc and that was a
halfway house now there's
you got crc you got chit i mean uh ciw
you got child chile you got uh
all those like six more prisons up north
for women
so imagine over that length of time how
much the crime has went up just with
females and young girls
young girls that are going to prison for
life
and have no possibility of parole
and it's sad because they never seeked
help
they took out
their revenges don't don't do that don't
ever do that don't ever
um how would i say this take things into
your own hands let the law handle it let
them that's what they're there for
you know don't don't take revenge
because that doesn't accomplish nothing
that does not accomplish nothing
you take the right steps do the right
thing and that's it
and that's all i can you know
pretty much say on that behalf
all right maria thank you so much for
sharing your story yeah
thank you
you